If we keep ourselves positive, if we
enjoy the process, we will be learning.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann, and
today I want to talk about like,
how do we know we're learning?
Okay.
Uh, remember, if you enjoy
my videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
If you're following me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So, very often when we're engaged
in some kind of language learning
activity, we don't know if we
are actually learning anything.
It's not like if we lift weights,
uh, our muscles are tired.
We have the sense that we have worked,
we've done some work, and we're fairly
confident that we're contributing
to a certain level of fitness once
we leave the gym or after working
out for half an hour, we do feel
a certain tightness in our body.
We feel that we've done something and
language learning is not like that.
So how do we know if we are
in fact achieving anything?
If we're reading, we might
enjoy what we're reading.
We might enjoy the subject matter.
If it's a novel or a book on
history or whatever it might be,
we might find that interesting.
But how do we know that we are
actually improving in the language if
that's what we would like to achieve?
Or conversely, if we're doing grammar,
or reading a dictionary, like how do
we know that we are actually improving?
I have read grammar books.
I have even leafed through dictionaries.
I never know if I'm actually
retaining anything, if I'm
actually learning anything.
Similarly, when I'm reading or listening
or even saving words on LingQ, how
do I know that I'm learning anything?
I don't know.
So my advice here is, is several,
first of all: Try to do things that you
enjoy doing so at the very least, even
if you don't have a sense that you're
improving, at least you have the sense
that you are enjoying what you're doing.
So I enjoy listening to my
whatever podcast it might
be in Persian, for example.
I enjoy doing that.
I enjoy doing the sentence view of
difficult content and then doing the
matching pairs and the sort of scrambled
sentence that I have to put back together
again, I alert you that this function
right now only exists in the iOS version.
We're trying to perfect it there,
and then we will introduce it as
well in Android and in the web
version, so please be patient.
I enjoy doing that.
It slows me down in terms of acquiring
new words, but it gives me a good
grasp of how the language works.
I enjoy doing that.
I don't know for a fact that I'm better
off doing that than just reading maybe.
And, and of course I vary it.
I do some, sort of, just reading
through without picking through the
sentence in such great detail, and
I vary it with this other activity.
But I'm not sure which of these activities
is helping me the most, but I do know
that whichever one I'm engaged in,
just reading or picking through the
sentences, I know I enjoy doing it.
So I think that's a very important factor.
Of course, over time you will
see that you have improved.
You will see that your word count
at LingQ has gone up, number
of LingQs created has gone up.
All of the statistics that we have
that measure your activity, these
are good indicators that you are
progressing in the language, even
if you're not aware of that feeling,
that you know you're getting better.
And I have said before that, In the
initial three to six months, we have
a sense of a steep progression as
we're learning high frequency words.
A language which had no meaning to
us, all of a sudden has meaning.
But then thereafter, there's this
long period, the plateau, the
doldrums, where we have no great
sense of progressing in the language.
And so we wonder, is this activity
actually enabling me to, you know, learn.
Am I learning?
And I think there it's
important to trust the process.
It's important to avoid doing
activities that you don't like doing.
Like I don't do drills.
I've seen suggestions that, for example,
after reading something, you should
try and summarize it in your own words.
I never do that.
To me that's unnatural.
I would rather just speak to someone.
I sometimes speak with my tutor.
Uh, some material that she has sent my
way, a podcast on, you know, Iranian
identity or whatever it might be.
I'd rather just naturally have
a conversation than try to sort
of artificially, uh, you know,
describe what it is I just read.
So I don't do those things.
I don't try to analyze what I'm doing.
I avoid doing things that I don't like.
But if you like doing those things,
by all means do them because it's so
hard in language learning to know at
any given point if in fact all of our
activities are contributing to learning.
So we're best off to do
things that we enjoy doing.
If we enjoy those things and
if we continue being active in
the language, we will learn.
We will learn.
And, and I go back to my famous, not my
famous, but the what this one director of
the language department at San Diego State
University once told me there's only three
things that matter in language learning:
the learner's attitude, time on...
time with the language
and the ability to notice.
But to me, the ability to notice
comes from a positive attitude,
a desire to notice, and spending
a lot of time with the language.
If we keep ourselves positive, if we
enjoy the process, we will be learning.
And there's all kinds of room
there for people to make their own
choices as to which activities they
prefer to do, which activities,
keep them active with the language.
And as long as you do
that, you will be learning.
Even though very often we don't have the
feeling that we're learning and uh, so you
know, how do we know if we're learning?
Uh, we should focus instead on how do
we know if we're enjoying the process.
And, uh, with that, I'll just leave
you with a couple of videos that
I've done over the past couple
of years on related subjects.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.